30-minute workouts 20-minute recipes
10-minute mindfulness ready to become
[Music]
get feel on the app store or google play
hi everyone it's joanna here today's
workout is a
40-minute tall-to-body traditional
strength training
that means we will be targeting each
muscle group
separately this is not a fast paced
workout it's not a high impact workout
we will take it slow because we want to
really
hit each muscle group and really build
your muscle strength all right
so there will be a total of three
circuits the first circuit will be
working on our lower body
second circuit on our upper body and the
third circuit
will be focusing on our core so
if you have a pair of dumbbells get your
dumbbells ready and let's start lifting
[Music]
if you only have one pair of dumbbells
then choose a medium weight pair of
dumbbells
i would say between four to six kilos if
you have two pairs
then go for medium weight as well as a
light pair of dumbbells okay
so let's start with a little bit of warm
up stand
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointed forward what i want you to do is
place your fingers
directly underneath your um toes and
just squat
back straighten legs squat down look
straight
and straighten your legs okay so we're
warming up
on our legs as well as stretching on our
hamstrings
good down push your butt back open up
your chest
and push it back
very nice good if you can't straighten
your knees that's fine
keep it slightly bent okay if you can't
grab your toes that's fine too
grab hold of your ankles squat and
up all right two more
last one and up okay
now let's do a little bit of side to
side lunges okay so step in the middle
step to the side feel the stretch on the
inner thighs as well as your outer
glutes
step back in the middle to the left
back in the middle and to the right
good step out push your butt back
and get your legs and step back in
push it back in
one more step out really go as low as
you can
and back in all right a little bit more
stretches
what a way to do is get into a lunge
position
okay what i want to do is just feel the
stretch
on your legs and now i want you to
switch over
stretch it out open up
reach the top good step back into a
plank
out stretch it up
last few more back step in
stretch up step back
in up and now
slowly come back
up all right so grab your dumbbells okay
the first workout is going to be a tempo
squat
so just place the dumbbells on your
shoulders what i'm going to do is
stance shoot straight with a pot and
slowly lower yourself down in three
counts
and push yourself back up in one count
okay so one
two three up remember we're not rushing
through our workout
i want you to really focus on your form
and really engage
your quads and your glutes push yourself
up
suck your belly in and up good
nice and easy and push yourself back
up all right so remember push your butt
back
up keep your elbows close
and up squeeze your glutes
right at the top all right
so drop one dumbbell we're getting into
a single leg lunge take your left leg
back
grab hold of the dumbbell on your right
hand again
simple movement all i need to do is
lunge down
and come back up okay i want you to lean
your body forward slightly
this way you will really feel the work
on
your right glutes good and place your
hand back
so all the work should only be on your
right
thigh back down
and up okay so lean your body forward
slightly
but still keeping your chest up right
so you're not hunching forward okay it's
just a slight lean
and up good one leg at a time
up straighten it up
push it back lower yourself down
if you want to you can look straight
ahead and
up good now let's change side okay
so left leg forward right leg back
switch over
again a slight lean forward right hand
back
and step back and get into a lunge
so your knee should be in line with
your toes if you can if you can try to
get your
right knee to tap the floor gently and
come back up
i really want you to go deep go low
and really feel the engagement in the
glutes and that
work on your glutes and your left
leg okay so this is not a fast pace
workout
we're not going to increase our heart
rate too much we're going to keep it at
a steady pace
but i want you to really feel the work
on each
muscle group back down
up down again
up
few more find your balance and
up all right place both dumbbells down
now let's get on to all fours
it's going to be a bridge leg sweep okay
so let's start on our left side what i'm
going to do is
kick back squeeze your glutes extend it
out
and immediately kick back and out to the
side so it's like a
sweep but at the same time
try not to rotate your hips too much
that constant squeeze should be
you should feel the constant squeeze on
your left glutes okay
that under butt squeeze it really lift
it up
try to keep it back flat squeeze it good
slow and nice and feel the work on your
outer thighs as well squeeze
kick it out up good there you go
feel that tension that's what we want
that constant contraction
and up all right now on your right side
so switch over again remember kick
back to to the side
back and to the side okay
kick it up good view the squeeze
on your glutes okay point your toes
out to the side straight back
as high as you can without overarching
your lower back
up squeezing good squeeze
extend up and to the side
good you might find that your body is
trying to
lean down when you're
sweeping your leg to the side so brace
your car
tighten your car pull it back kick it
back
very nice out up squeeze last two more
push it squeeze it one more and up
okay now let's work on our outer thighs
okay
if you want to you can grab the
dumbbells or you can do this workout
without
the dumbbell so it's going to be a side
leg raise with
weights okay so point your toes lift it
up to the side
with the dumbbell on your thigh you're
going to feel extra
um tension and it's going to make your
leg work a lot harder so it's going to
really scalp
that outer thigh if this is too much
drop the dumbbells okay a gentle tap and
up don't rest tap
up squeeze i can feel it burning up
nice as high as you can remember
that your legs should be slightly back
okay
so do not go forward this is wrong back
up and down feel the burn
keep the tension good and now let's
switch over oh good
very good doing really well again
just gently place the dumbbell on your
thigh and ready
point kick it up down
and up okay if you don't have a dumbbell
you can also use a plate
push it up tap it down up
good chest upright do not sink
push your shoulders away
tap and up there you go
lift it up good keep going
and we want to repeat the entire circuit
again
right after this good job keep going
up feel the burn let's not stop right
now
squeeze few more give me three more one
two last one more squeeze and
now just come back up okay
grab your weights we're starting from
the first workout which is a tempo squat
all right
so remember stand shoulder width apart
point your toes and your knees
forward do not step too wide or go too
narrow okay
and gently rest the dumbbells on
your shoulders all right chest up
stand tall push your butt back and
one two three push yourself back up
squeeze your glutes right at the top
good
i want to see a deep squat go low
up there you go very good
up as you can see all these workouts
it's working on one muscle group at a
time
and it's very specific okay it's not a
functional movement but rather it's
really
targeting each individual muscle group
down and up good push your butt back
up keep your elbows close to your body
squeeze down up
one more up and
good drop one weight
okay are we ready single leg lunge
let's start with our right side forward
left leg back
find your balance brace your core look
forward and remember a slight
lean forward just a slight lean tap down
and come back up okay low lunge
try to get your left knee to tap the
floor
and push up with your right
heel up squeeze your right glutes
good so you're just grabbing
on to the dumbbell okay not too tight
good done it up push it up
keep your back flat
breathe out as you come up
good up
good again we're not rushing through the
workout so slow down
fuss up okay now let's switch over
all right left leg forward right leg
back
hands dumbbell on your left hand ready a
slight lean forward
let's go tap and push up
okay so find a comfortable
spot where you're able to balance
yourself so don't step
too wide or too narrow good
back down push up
and remember don't lock your knees okay
keep a slight bend throughout
good squeeze your left glutes
feel the burn keep going that's the
tension we want
feel it right
on your glutes your hamstrings and
your thighs good lunge
up and down okay
drop the dumbbell okay now
let's get into the
lake bridge sweep okay so get onto all
fours
starting on one leg kick it back
sweep it to the side up squeeze
remember as you squeeze wholly for one
count
and slowly drive it to the side okay
i want you to feel the contraction
before
you sweep your leg out
squeeze good breathe out and squeeze
let's do it together very nice
right at the
under butt good push it point the toast
give me two more okay let's go two more
one two
and now let's switch over all right
still on all fours brace your core keep
your back flat
spread your fingers if you need to and
ready kick your
left leg back to the side up
squeeze to the side and up
very good again remember that you should
be
pushing away from your shoulders
to the side squeeze
out do not drop your legs try to
maintain a straight line
squeeze good feel the stretch on your
hamstrings
and the tension on your glutes
keep going breathe out
with every contraction breathe out
good come let's kick it higher good job
last few more last one more give me one
more okay
up and back down okay
choose your option either with or
without a dumbbell
okay side leg raise so just gently
rest your upper body straighten one leg
and ready raise it up point tap down
up tap up
good so just gently rest the dumbbell
on your thigh and feel the work
on your outer thigh okay
and also your glutes your outer glutes
as well
up good gentle tap
we want to maintain the tension do not
rest right now
keep the tension going feel the burn
that's what we want
breathe out oh gosh
it is burning there you go slow movement
yet very effective to build muscles
up down up and down
good change side okay
this is the final workout for your lower
body circuit
so give me your best effort
dumbbell on your thigh ready let's
finish this
strong tap up
down up good job
you you should find that one leg is
usually stronger
than the other so my left my right leg
is stronger tap and
down good and remember again
breathe out as you raise your
leg up
good keep going
look forward up squeeze it
hold for one count right at the top back
down
up down up
last two more up one more
up and good job just drop the dumbbell
take a shot one minute break and we want
to move
into our upper body circuit
[Music]
for the second circuit we'll be
splitting the exercises to work
on your back your chest shoulders
as well as your arms okay so grab
the heavier dumbbell okay for the first
workout
we will be working on your back muscles
so it's going to be
a row with a reverse fly so let me just
show you
again stand shoulder width apart with
your toes pointer forward keep a slight
bend on your knee and i just want you to
slowly bend from your hips remember do
not hunch okay
flat back pull the dumbbell towards your
waist
and then now pull it out
so remember dumbbell towards your waist
spread your wings
and fly good so
point your elbows back to begin with and
now spread your elbows
out so it's a row and a
reverse fly this is going to work on
your lats
your traps your rhomboids basically
every part of the back muscles
and remember a slight hinge forward
good maintain that position row
and reverse fly good point your elbows
back
reverse fly very good the second
exercise
is going to work on your shoulders
alternating
are not pressed so start
by keeping your palms facing towards you
okay
so what we're going to do is to rotate
and
press the dumbbell up one
at a time okay so always keep your
elbows close to you
press it up feel the work on your
shoulders and
back down there you go so rotate your
wrist
out and press the dumbbell up
using the strength from your shoulders
avoid
this okay don't do this if you're doing
this
then the weight is too heavy for you
brace your core keep a slight bend on
your knee
and press the dumbbell straight up
very good there you go
and back down okay this time i want you
to drop
the dumbbells and grab a lighter pair of
dumbbells
i would say between one to three kilos
the next workout
we're going to work on your side delt
and also your front delt okay
so it's going to be a side raise and
a front raise good so spread your arms
out to the side
and drive your arms forward
remember that your palm should always be
facing
down don't do this this is wrong
palm facing down point your elbows back
and keep a slight bend on your elbows
so this is not an easy workout our
shoulder
are small muscles basically so you can
grab
lighter weights okay forward
and side good
spread to the side and forward again
avoid bouncing good and drop it
still with the lighter pair of dumbbells
we're going to work on our arms
specifically on our triceps so tricep
kick back
again just like the first workout hinge
forward slightly
keep your elbows tight kick the
dumbbells
back okay so as you can see i'm
only moving my forearm and i'm squeezing
my
triceps right at the top
okay hold it for one count right at the
top and lower it back down
good so it's not this this is wrong
keep your elbows close move your forearm
bend from forearm squeeze your triceps
right at the top
lower it back down up back down
and up good breathe
out as you drive the dumbbells up
good slowly lower it back down with
control very good now drop the dumbbells
get down onto the floor grab your
heavier pair of dumbbells
this is going to be a bridge fly okay
so this is going to work on your chest
lift your
butt off the floor dumbbells up
spread your elbows and bring it in
that's it
so gentle tap on the floor and drive the
dumbbells
in palms facing
in alright use the strength from your
chest
to drive the dumbbells in and squeeze
good if this is too heavy you can use
the lighter dumbbells and remember keep
your glutes up
squeeze your glutes i want you to be
working on your glutes at the same time
squeeze it do the work on the chest if
this is too much
just drop your butt and just focus
on your chest good so choose
your option very good now slowly come
back up the finisher is going to be a
renegade
roll i love this exercise because it
works on your chest
your shoulders your back as well as your
arms
so grab the dumbbells get into a plank
position
we want to add a push-up and
a row okay so spread
your feet wide one push up to work on
your chest
and as you roll it's going to work on
your back
your shoulders as well as your core to
balance you
good roll push up
if this is too tough remember choose the
easier option
get onto your knees if not
stay with me this is your final workout
for this circuit and we'll repeat the
entire circuit
once more row good it's a challenge
but it's a good challenge up row
and row all right
okay short break let's
get back up grab your dumbbells first
workout
is going to be a row and a reverse fly
okay
so we're starting with our back so again
point your toes forward keep a slight
bend bend from your hips
do not drop chest up push your butt back
a little bit
remember keep your elbows tight
pull the dumbbells in spread your elbows
out
pull the dumbbells in good spread it
and pull good the contraction
should be on your back
and remember slowly lower the dumbbells
down
do not just release the dumbbells roll
out very good this is a great combo
for your back muscles roll
and out there you go
and just gently gaze
on the floor okay keep a neutral
neck good one more
reverse fly and come back up
all right alternating are not pressed
okay
so bring the dumbbells up pumps facing
you and now rotate your wrist
press it up rotate and press
good job keep pressing it up and
up one at a time okay
fully focusing on one shoulder at a time
so remember slowly lower the dumbbell
down
do not just let it collapse press up
the dumbbell should be right above your
head okay good job strong arms strong
shoulders
push it very good up
breathe out as you push up
a few more one more on each side
and last one and now
drop it grab your lighter pair of
dumbbells
if you don't have any you can even do
the workout without
any dumbbells okay it's going to be a
side
to a front raise ready
out keep your elbows bent forward
good raise your core spread it to the
side
up very good nice and controlled okay
don't just let the weights drop up
control forward nice
spread feel the squeeze on your side
and your front shoulders up
good job small muscles but we have to
work on them okay
if you want a nice and defined arms
this is one of the best exercises to do
up
spread it out forward
that's one more forward
and okay tricep kickbacks okay
so just like the first workout keep your
knees slightly bent
lean forward tuck your elbows close to
your body
only moving forearm let's go kick it
back hold it for one count
up hold it squeeze at the top
that squeeze is going to really help you
to develop
strong muscles okay every rep
counts every wrap should be a quality
wrap so make it worth it squeeze
don't rush through the workout squeeze
very good
feel the contraction on your triceps up
down there you go up and down
hold it stay with me holy
good strong arms ladies let's go
up down one more
up and down okay drop
the dumbbells grab your heavier dumbbell
let's get down onto the floor into
a bridge position dumbbell straight
up bridge position let's go
chest fly okay
spread your elbows out a gentle tap
on the floor and bring it back up okay
brace your core squeeze your glutes
squeeze your chest up so your dumbbells
should be in one straight line with your
chest it should not be
too high or too low look
directly at your dumbbells feel the
contraction
on your chest up
nice and controlled down and
up good job
up let's go love it or hate it
we got to make our upper body strong
okay a finisher workout renegade
row one of the toughest
but best workout for your upper body and
we're going to add
a push-up so spread your feet wide
one push-up row
and row if this is too tough what you
can do
is release one hand place it on the
floor
and row and do a normal push-up
and row okay this
is an option if you have strong wrists
then stay with me
push up hold on to the dumbbells and
row remember keep your back
flat okay do not pike this
is wrong back flat but down
push up strong arms
one more and just
rest it out oh my gosh can you believe
it
you have completed two circuits
lower body upper body and the finisher
is going to be your core okay we're
going to be working on
our upper abs lower abs as well as our
obliques
so take a short break
[Music]
for this final round you can choose to
do all the exercises without any weights
if you want to challenge yourself then
grab one dumbbell okay
so we will be on our mat throughout the
entire workout
so lie on your back grab your weight
or you can choose to do without any
weights it's going to be
a full crunch so the first workout what
i want to do is raise
your leg to a 90 degree position extend
the dumbbell out
crunch in drive your knee into your
chest extend your legs straight
crunch in and out
good so do not rest your legs
on the floor okay this is a full crunch
working on your upper as well as
your lower abs remember to only extend
your legs
straight out without overarching
your lower back so really squeeze your
core engage your core
tighten it and breathe out
as you come up good
working on our core muscles
last two more crunch up
and drop the dumbbell okay
we won't need any weights the next
workout is going to be
alternating leg raises so this workout
will focus
more on your lower abs what i want to do
is just
place your hands by your head lift your
shoulders off slightly
straighten your legs and just alternate
your legs up and down
okay if you can't this is too tough what
you can do
is bend your knees
this works too okay so choose your
option
if not straight legs straight legs
up and down
good breathe out okay
this is a painful workout but it's
really good
for your lower abs so no rush
one step at a time breathe out
and out ah i can feel the burn
okay get back up let's get into a plank
position
and we want to work on spiderman plank
and this is going to be for your
obliques okay
so get into a high plank drive your left
knee to your left elbow
right to your right elbow okay nice and
easy
feel the work on your obliques
good spread your
knees out open up your hips and
try to get your knee to your elbow
good keep going
stay in a high plank do not pike your
butt
up okay maintain this position
stay in a high plank good knee to elbow
very good
keep going you're almost there that's
one more
and just drop onto your knees okay
the final workout is a really simple yet
effective workout
plank that's all we're gonna do okay
simple
yet effective and i want you to really
focus on your core
and just hold it for 45 seconds
okay so keep your back flat
push away from your shoulders okay so
remember
this is not a plank this is not a plank
okay
back flat and really brace your core
suck your belly in tighten your core
feel the shake if your entire body is
shaking that's all right
that is normal okay i want you to really
feel the work on your entire body not
just your core
but you should feel the work on your
upper body as well as your legs
hold it a nice solid plank
only five seconds left five four
three two and one okay
ah that is the end
of our call circuit and we want to
repeat the entire thing
once more all right so now let's lie
on your back choose your option with
or without the weights okay you're
towards the end of your workout
so everything is that
little bit more challenging all right
grab onto your weights lift your legs up
keep it at a 90 degree position extend
your arms out
crunch in extend it out
and in good
breathe out breathe in and
breathe out okay the goal is to get your
shoulders
off the floor and drive your knee
close to your chest extend it out
and in good job
just focus on every rep
again if this is too much i don't want
you to
um i don't want you to stop the workout
drop
the weight okay last one more
out and just drop the weight
all right are we ready for alternating
leg raises okay
just gonna quickly tie my hair
all right so arms by your head
extend your legs choose your option okay
so you can
drive one knee in and extend one leg
or if you want a more challenging option
straight legs up and
down okay choose your option
my abs is absolutely burning
let's not stop right now go for the
easier option okay stay with me
finish the workout strong
and just look straight ahead or gaze
at the ceiling
oh my god if you're feeling the burn
like me
let me know in the comments below okay
get back up
time to work on your obliques spiderman
plank all right so the goal here is to
spread your fingers apart
for you to have a better base get up and
now
drive your knee out and
forward good there you go one step at a
time
keep your back flat tighten your core
and just drive it forward good
without
strong core let's finish this
push good that's few more
give me two more
that's one more and drop
okay oh my god oh
core exercises are always more
challenging
okay but you have to build a strong core
in order to have a strong foundation
let's end with a plank okay on your
elbows
ready hole
i know the last place that you want to
be right now is right here
but i want you to finish the workout
strong with me okay
so just know that you've gone this far
you've gotten this far through the
workout you are strong and we will
finish
this workout strong you only have 20
seconds left
hold it tighten your core
squeeze feel the shake i am shaking with
you
ten seconds left do not drop right now
five seconds four three
two and one oh my gosh
okay now let's just get into
a child's pose and just slowly
stretch it out
take this time to breathe
all right okay very very well done you
have completed
a total body strength training workout
okay
we have worked on our lower body our
upper body as well as our core
so let's spend two to three minutes to
stretch our body out
okay so what i'm going to do is just lie
on your belly
pumps by your side and just get into a
cobra
and push yourself away from the mat and
feel the stretch on your lower back
your core as well as your arms okay
and remember you're pushing away from
your shoulders
do not sink in push away
and just look straight ahead very good
and just breathe right here
all that hard work well done
and now it's important to also stretch
your muscles out
because it will help to reduce muscle
soreness
and now just bring your
left leg forward okay we want to stretch
out the hip flexor
and just drive your arms up push your
weight
forward all right push your weight
forward
for those of you with type hip flexor
you will really feel this stretch
up look straight ahead and hold here
for 10 counts
and now slowly drop your arms and twist
to the side
and just look as far back as you can
[Music]
okay and now straighten the front leg
and feel the stretch on your hamstrings
okay we've done a lot of work on our
legs
so let's just gently stretch the
hamstrings out i have tight hamstrings
so this is really important for me
stretch it out
good and now bend the front leg
into a 90 degree position straighten
your back leg
and i just want you to slowly lower and
drop your body
this is going to again stretch your hip
flexor but also your glutes
okay so only go as far as you can if
this is your limit
that's fine if you can go lower then
rest your elbows
onto the mat for those of you who are
super flexible
then by all means extend forward okay
and remember with every stretch don't
fight against it
breathe into the stretch
and really just embrace it okay don't
over stretch as well
and now slowly come back up and now push
your left leg back
bring your right leg forward we're going
to repeat the entire stretch
on the other side again arms up remember
drop your body weight forward good
so you should feel the stretch on your
left hip
flexor right here extend
flat back look straight ahead
and just hold the stretch for 10 to 15
counts
okay good and now slowly
drop your arms twist and look the
opposite side
as far as you can keep your back flat
feel the stretch on your spine
your lower back
good and now straighten your front leg
stretch your hamstrings
good so avoid bouncing okay
just hold the stretch
and now just fold your front
leg drop the back leg
and again drop your body forward
either on your elbows on your palms or
all the way forward
and just hold it right here
very good
and slowly push yourself back up
okay guys very well done
that's a 40 minute workout okay
i hope that you will continue to do this
workout
because this will really help you to
build muscle mass
and to also get you stronger okay what
you can do is combine this workout with
my other
hit workouts to add in the cardio
element
and if you enjoyed this video give this
video a thumbs up
add this to your playlist do this
workout consistently for at least
um four weeks repeat it two to three
times weekly
and do check out my youtube channel for
a lot more
other full length workouts as well as
healthy recipes
and i will see you in my next workout
session all the best let me know in the
comments below
how you felt